that felt honestly liberating for me and
I just want to say up here will I have
the opportunity is if anyone I'm sorry
if anyone ever feels like they're scared
to do something because they got made
fun of or bullied I want you to know
that you can do it tonight was very
emotional for you there were many tears
there was tears before there was tears
after and I love this about Dancing with
the Stars cuz it's like therapy in
rhinestones
so what iconic that's it feel like now
that you've sort of told this part of
your story that I didn't really know I
know a lot of people don't know it they
kind of see you know this this pop
artist and I know she came exactly and
you're up in front the cameras the glitz
and glamor but they don't really get to
see the person behind and they're
Dancing with the Stars I get to see who
I am and see what my journey is all
about and you know I had that background
of being made fun of her my dancing and
I came on the show to say you know what
like those people negativity I'm here to
prove not only to but to myself that I
can do this and also hope to be an
inspiration for someone else so it's
it's honestly amazing and your scores
reflected that this week they really
were digging you much better than that
last week how do you feel for me it's
all about Ally and I think her journey
is so important she has so much to give
so much to show and today I was just an
opening next week's gonna be incredible
and I can't wait
retweet that how have your fans reacted
to this because I do know that you have
a crazy fan base I mean the fan base
alone Ally could take you to the finals
you know there they are crazy what were
they saying to online and what have you
heard from them so and a good stuff so I
went on my Twitter in between the show
today and Instagram and all that the
comments were they just swept the floor
for me they were so positive they were
so moved by a performance and there they
were there to see me you know grow and
so the comments have been stupendous and
marvelous and it makes me feel so happy
to know that I have so much love now
it's different
it's beautiful and I'm only gonna get
better for them and thank you guys
allegiance for always supporting me it
means the world a negative support both
of us what I love is that I've seen you
and seen you grow up most of your career
in like a booty short and like a pop
star outfit and you're like a lady
[Music]